zach lauther's numbers on the year
making his sixth start he picked up his
first big league win his last timeout
and the 3-2
sharply that ricochets off martin it's
short and [ __ ] is going to be safe
he hit a couple right on the button that
one right ad martin
[Applause]
they'll get one at second yes just got
there
with the shift on
pat valaka had to hustle to the bag and
just get the force out on hernandez one
down with renfro reaching on the
fielder's choice
[Applause]
to second for one on the first and it's
a double play
devers to short on assistant over to
first orioles turn two come to that
scoreless
nate 10-9 era of 388 he suffered through
his worst performance of the season last
time out
mullen's been up 17 times against nate
vivaldi has struck him out seven times
and gets him again it was 99. there's a
taste in cheese from vivaldi
and the o2 pitch
oh is that filthy he struck him out
caught him looking
two up two down boy he's not messing
around one two three puts him away with
the curve ball
that's a fair ball
down into the left field corner hayes
around first heading for second verdugo
fires and he's in with a double
2-1 pitch to mancini
i pop up
and here's ren throwing right
to retire the side 82 83 27 almost 96
runs batted in one out nobody on the
pitch dwing there's a drive hammer to
deep center field mullins won't get this
one it is long gone
deep over the center field fence home
run
for j.d number 28 is 97th rbi and it's
one nothing boston that goes 444 feet he
touched that off that's a no doubter
absolute no doubter
oh
nasty nate with the splitage oh just
waiting for a punch out this thing when
he's got that working forget about it
[Applause]
hurry up fastball on the corner see ya
boy he is all business back-to-back case
he has four already he's faced six
batters
i mean this is the best of vivaldi is it
not a hurry up fastball on the corner
trying to fan
balaka
and he does yeah he hooked him and
struck him out he strikes out the side
here
there's a line drive and they turn two
line drive into the glove of gutierrez
and at second base iglesias gets doubled
off that's one way to do it
[Applause]
ever sitting in a double play in the
first inning after they made an error in
the very first play of the game
and a grounded a third gutierrez very
good over there
and time to get the out the red sox fail
to add on
2-2 hit the other way over the leaping
shortstop
roduko serving a single to the outfield
reds actually have the leadoff man on
1-1 from louder
hit up the middle that's through for a
base hit
jose is two for two first two men with
singles here in the fifth inning
2-1 breaking ball down to third there's
one over to first and the orioles turn
two
red sox have already gotten pretty tired
with themselves doing that tonight
hitting into double plays
ground ball oh that gets through
gutierrez finally he doesn't make a play
raffy devers down to third he'll stop
there that's going to be an air on
gutierrez
shocking absolutely shocking red sacks
catch a break second and third nobody
out for j.d
line drive and that's fair down into the
corner
devers is in the score
bogart's coming in to score
jd martinez ripping a two-run double and
a red sox add-on it's now three to
nothing
that's what you do
you get a lot of room over there in the
shift and you knock it down and you've
got yourself a double
said rick mullins continues his
sensational season the most valuable
oriole crowned tonight down the field
prior to this game
his 89th pitch
yes he did
97 he strikes him out
that's what i'm talking about
trying to keep the shutout intact
swinging a little flare in the center
field hangs for [ __ ] and he's got it
nathan avaldi gives up a double walks
him in and gets out of it
oh feeling good about himself tonight i
don't blame you had to sleep on that
that stinker he had against new york for
five nights i've been there and
he's feeling good and he should that's a
great outing for him seven strikeouts
one walk but pitched around trouble a
couple of times
desperately needed outing
by the red sox so he gives way to
brazier ryan brazier
been throwing the ball very well as egg
mentioned on the comeback trail
swinging and a miss to put him away
he strikes out belaka
one gun yeah back to back sliders gets
him good sliders down and
away the payoff pitch and strikes him
out with some rising heat
and freezes that man at second
three-nothing boston sends up for dugo
one for three with a single
line driving a basin into left field
bogarts is in to score
martinez coming around
he will score
sean a rundown tagged out but two runs
come in to score
verdugo in the clutch
two down base faces empty
he swings and tags that one to left
center field carrying back and she's
gone
into the bleachers
number 30
for hunter renfro
he one-handed it a home run for hunter
renfro he hits number 30 drives in his
93rd run of the year
and extends the hit straight to 10 games
with a two out ninth inning home run six
nothing red sox use the two nothing
lined into left field and the catch will
be made out there by verdugo for out
number two
so one more out to get
and the red sox will have their 89th
victory
popped up there's shaw and that's a win
an absolute must win for the red sox
tonight and a blank baltimore's six to
nothing the final score
[Applause]